mentos and coke we've seen this before
know what you do right you got some coke
get some Mentos oh whoa that's pretty
cool good great yeah
oh good I like to nollie flip through
that stream of coke yeah I want to give
that go I think we should do at the same
time both of us but the hell's gonna put
the Mentos in the bowl oh all right this
is Georgia
what is your channel called @gb film
productions GB film productions okay
everyone should check that out
get some short films they're cool and
have you ever put Mentos in a coke
bottle before never I've never done that
before
what's your fridge gonna be like what
are you gonna you got get as many in his
pocket yeah I'm just gonna try and flood
it all in there and see how high you can
go yeah there's a lot of technique to
this you know yeah yeah I've been doing
it for a few years now so with a touch
thing yeah yeah this is gonna be mega
life yeah starting cut already yes
probably yes
ready yeah
so we finally filmed Mentos and Coke
like everyone's been asking for for
about a year
doctor thought rather well good good
altitude on the coat yeah
tryna meant oh yeah I've never had a
mentor no I've never trained with them
they're trying out of this mines will
hold all mines kind of wet and sticky
you trying to trying to get one from the
bottom
it went down my throat whoa I think I
think put them in diet coke is actually
what they were designed for
yeah they rescued you they said I won't
fish you sure they won't decide for
consumption anything
so you're the next one
you